>> Greg: WELCOME BACK.
JEOPARDY GETS IN TROUBLE FOR
MAKING MURDER A DAILY DOUBLE.
YEAH.
THIS GAME SHOW GETS A GRILLING
OVER A CLUE THAT USED A REAL
KILLING.
JEOPARDY FANS WERE STUNNED BY A
SUNDAY NIGHT EPISODE WHEN A
QUESTION ABOUT ALLIGATORS USED
MURDERER BRIAN LAUNDRIE AS A
CLUE.
LAUNDRY WAS THE CREEP WHO KILLED
HIS GIRLFRIEND GABBY BA TITO
LAST YEAR IN GRAND TITAN
NATIONAL PARK AND THEN WENT ON
THE LAMB KILLING HIMSELF IN A
FLORIDA SWAMP.
ENOUGH BACK STORY, ROLL THE TAPE
SILL VI 0.
>> IN 2021 FUGITIVE BRIAN
LAUNDRIE ENDED HIS DAYS IN
FLORIDA'S CREEK AREA HOME TO
THESE LONG AND TOOTHY CRITTERS.
JOEL.
>> WHAT ARE ALLIGATORS?
>> Harris: WOW.
>> Greg: THAT IS LIKE THE MOST
BIZARRE QUESTION EVER.
VIEWERS ARE CALLING THE
INCLUSION OF LAUNDRY TASTELESS
AND UNNECESSARY.
EVEN ALLIGATORS COMPLAINED
SAYING ON TWITTER, WHAT DID WE
DO TO DESERVE THIS OTHER THAN
EAT PEOPLE?
BUT I HAVE TO ADMIT PERSONALLY
IT DOES MAKE JEOPARDY MORE FUN.
LIKE HERE'S ONE I CAME UP WITH.
JEFFREY DAHMER WAS A SERIAL
KILLER WHO ATE HIS VICTIMS MUCH
LIKE THIS TYPE OF PYTHON FOUND
IN AFRICA.
I COULD DO THAT ALL DAY.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: YOU SEE IT WORKS.
EVIL JEOPARDY.
BUT IN TRUE JEOPARDY FASHION
WE'RE LEFT WITH MORE QUESTIONS
THAN ANSWERS.
LIKE WHY TIE A QUESTION ABOUT
GATORS TO A RECENT GRIZZLY
MURDER?
THEY COULD HAVE JUST SAID THIS
GIANT SWAMP LIZARD LIVES IN
FLORIDA BUT I GUESS TOO MANY
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE SAID CHARLIE
CRIST.
KAT, DO YOU THINK THE WRITERS
WERE TOLD TO SPICE UP THEIR
QUESTIONS BECAUSE MAYBE THEY
FELT THE SHOW WAS LOSING A BIT
AFTER LACKS TREBEK PASSED AWAY
SO THEY WANTED TO MAKE IT
SHOCKING AND EDGY
>> Kat: JEOPARDY'S NEVER GOING
TO BE EDGY I DON'T THINK THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR WHEN
YOU'RE WATCHING IT.
I LOVE BRIAN LAUNDRIE'S ATTORNEY
CAME OUT AND SAID YOU GUYS ARE
RIGHT THIS IS GROSS WE DEMAND AN
APOLOGY.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE WERE MAD ON
BEHALF OF YOUR MURDERER BOY BUT
I DO WANT TO BE ON CELEBRITY
JEOPARDY NOW
>> Greg: WHY?
>> Kat: BECAUSE THE ANSWERS ARE
THINGS LIKE WHAT'S AN ALLIGATOR.
I KNOW WHAT AN ALLIGATOR IS.
NOT TO BRAG.
>> Greg:.
>> Greg: THAT'S NOT HOW JEOPARDY
WORKS
>> Kat: APPARENTLY IT IS NOW.
>> Greg: NO, THE QUESTION IS THE
ANSWER
>> Kat: I JUST SAID A CORRECT
WAY.
YOU'RE NOT GOOD AT LISTENING.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
>> Tyrus: YOU JUST FIGURED THAT
OUT AFTER SIX YEARS?
>> Kat: NO I KNEW.
>> Greg: NO, I LISTEN TO YOU
GUYS RIGHT NOW.
>> Tyrus: WHAT DID I JUST SAY.
>> Greg: YOU SAID I'M NOT A GOOD
LISTENER
>> Kat: YOU GOT THAT USING
CONTEXT CLUES.
>> Harris: THE KIDS ARE
FIGHTING.
>> Greg: I LOVE THESE QUESTIONS.
TED BUNDY MURDERED NURSES IN THE
EARLY 70s WHICH RAISES THE
QUESTION, WHAT IS THE MOST
COMMON BLOOD TYPE.
>> Tyrus: OKAY.
THE ANSWER TO ALL YOUR LITTLE
QUESTIONS, WHAT IS ROCK PYTHON,
TYPE A.
>> Greg: THAT'S RIGHT.
IT IS A ROCK PYTHON.
>> Tyrus: THANK YOU.
YEAH, THANK YOU.
>> Harris: I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T FIND THIS FUNNY OR
HELPFUL.
I'M THINKING OF GABBY PETITO'S
FAMILY.
>> Greg: WAY TO BRING US DOWN.
>> Harris: AND OF THOSE VICTIMS.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING
THE STORY HARRIS WE DON'T LIKE
IT EITHER BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
SHOW THE ABSURDITY OF IT.
>> Harris: I'M THINKING OF
JEFFREY DAHMER AND THE WHOLE
SERIES THEY JUST DID NOT OF HIM
BUT THEIR VICTIMS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
AND I COVER THESE STORIES.
SO I MEAN I'M NOT GOING TO
LAUGH.
>> Greg: OH.
WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO LEAVE.
>> Harris: NO, I'M NOT LEAVING.
>> Greg: I'M JOKING HARRIS.
>> Harris: I'M GOING TO MAKE YOU
READ SOME OF THAT BOOK AND FIND
SOME FAITH.
>> Greg: I'M READING -- TOMORROW
I'M FLYING AND I WILL I'M GOING
TO BRING IT ON THE FLIGHT.
I DON'T THINK IT'S COMFORTING TO
THE OTHER PASSENGERS WHEN YOU
HAVE A BOOK ON PRAYER.
YOU'RE READING THE BOOK.
SHE WROTE HER OWN PRAYERS.
>> Harris: IT'S ALL ABOUT
MIRACLES.
>> Greg: READ THEM OUT LOUD
WHILE WE'RE GOING DOWN.
JIM DO YOU THINK THIS WAS A
STUNT TO GET PRESS.
>> Jim: HOW WAS THIS EVEN A
STORY.
LIKE FOUR PEOPLE ON TWITTER WERE
OFFENDED AND THEY MADE A WHOLE
STORY ABOUT THIS, THEY WENT ON
THE TWITTER FEED AND SAW FOUR
PEOPLE AND SAID LOOK AT THESE
PEOPLE OUTRAINED.
>> Greg: DON'T YOU THIS I IT'S A
FUN STORY.
>> Jim: IT IS AND PEOPLE WILL
ALWAYS BE OFFENDED.
I WENT TO MY GIRLFRIEND'S WORK
HALLOWEEN PARTY WHICH YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO LIKE BECAUSE I DRESSED
UP LIKE JEFFREY DAHMER.
>> Harris: YOU GUYS ARE LIKE
BESTIES.
>> Jim: EVERYONE'S GOING TO BE
OFFENDED AND NO ONE'S GOING TO
TALK TO YOU AND I WAS LIKE GOOD
THAT'S WHY I'M DOING IT, I DON'T
WANT ANYONE TO TALK TO ME.
I'LL BE AT THE BAR BY MYSELF
DRINKING AND NO ONE'S GOING TO
TALK TO ME.
AND NO ONE DID IT WAS GREAT.
>> Harris: NO THEY'RE TERRIFIED.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT'S GREAT I
LOVE HOW YOU SAID FOR HALLOWEEN
YOU DRESSED UP AS JEFFREY DAHMER
WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY JUST THAT
AND KETCHUP.
>> Jim: AND GLASSES.
>> Greg: OH MY GOD THAT'S ONE OF
MY FAVORITE STORIES OF ALL TIME.
>> Tyrus: I SEE FAULKNER'S POINT
BUT HERE'S WHERE WE RUN INTO
PROBLEMS WHENEVER THERE'S A MASS
MURDER ON THIS SHOW TO NEVER SAY
THEIR NAME.
AND WE ALWAYS SEEM TO
EVENTUALLY, THE MURDERER, LIKE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ON THE FIVE
TODAY, YOU RATHER HAVE BEEN THE
MURDERER SO YOU COULD LIVE
LONGER.
>> Harris: WOW.
THAT'S CLASSY.
.
>> Tyrus: THE PERPETRATOR ALWAYS
IS REMEMBERED.
>> Harris: IT'S SO TRUE.
>> Tyrus: THEY NEVER MAKE THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE VICTIM
BECAUSE WE STILL HAVE THIS
PROBLEM IN THIS COUNTRY WHERE
BEING A MARTYR FOR DOING BAD
THINGS AND THEN UNFORTUNATELY
SOME IDIOT WILL SIT AT HOME AND
BE LIKE, I'LL BE A JEOPARDY
QUESTION?
I'LL BE A NETFLIX SERIES?
>> Harris: I'LL BE GREG' FRIEND.
>> Tyrus: THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
YOU CAN'T BE MAD AT JEOPARDY
BECAUSE IT'S THE ENTIRE MEDIA
SYSTEM THAT'S HOW IT WORKS.
>> Harris: IT'S TRUE WE TALK